hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr mit dabei seid
den geschlechtseintrag und den Vornamen
ändern lassen das soll für trans- und
intergeschlechtliche sowie nicht binäre
Menschen einfacher werden und zwar durch
das sogenannte selbstbestimmungsgesetz
das hat die Bundesregierung heute
beschlossen dieses
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das soll das
über 40 Jahre alte Transsexuellengesetz
ablösen dieses sei demütigend und des
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es sogar in
wesentlichen Teilen für
verfassungswidrig erklärt
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann der
hat zu diesem Vorhaben der
Bundesregierung und zum neuen
selbstbestimmungsgesetz heute morgen bei
uns im ZDF folgendes gesagt und das
Verfassungsgericht hat auch gesagt so
wie ist der Gesetzgeber in der
Vergangenheit gemacht hat darf man es
nicht weitermachen und wir wollen jetzt
einfach einer kleinen Gruppe für die das
große Bedeutung hat das Leben einfach
etwas leichter machen
also für diese Betroffene für die kleine
Gruppe wie Sie Marco Busch man nennt ist
dieser Gesetzentwurf historisch es gibt
aber auch teils heftige Kritik an dem
Vorhaben der Bundesregierung das Gesetz
Schwäche zum Beispiel den Kinder- und
Jugendschutz und öffne die Tür für
Missbrauch ist das wirklich so was
ändert sich genau und welche
Konsequenzen hat dieses Gesetz darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen und zwar mit
Julia Monroe Aktivistin für die rechte
Trans geschlechtlicher Menschen uns mit
meinem Kollegen Samuel Kirsch aus
unserer ZDF rechtsredaktion und
natürlich auch mit euch deswegen stellt
eure Fragen wie immer sehr gerne direkt
hier im Youtube Chat ihr könnt auch eure
Gedanken zum Thema loswerden oder ihr
schreibt Sie uns per Mail an sie
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse die Date
die lautet ZDF heute - live.at zdf.de
und ich versuche dann so viele Fragen
und Gedanken von euch wie möglich hier
im Stream mit unterzubringen eine kleine
Bitte noch von mir bevor wir hier in die
Diskussion starten über dieses Thema
wurde in der Vergangenheit wirklich in
Teilen heftig gestritten deswegen
diskutiert und kommentiert hier sehr
gerne mit aber bitte mach das
respektvoll so bevor ich jetzt gleich
mit Julia Monroe spreche die ich schon
angekündigt habe und wir in die
Diskussion einsteigen wollen wir uns
einmal zusammen anschauen um was genau
ist in diesem selbstbestimmungsgesetz
geht und das hat meine Kollegin Lena
jentscher für euch zusammengefasst
das Bundeskabinett hat heute den
Gesetzentwurf zum
selbstbestimmungsgesetz gebilligt für
transgeschlechtliche
intergeschlechtliche und nicht binäre
Menschen soll es in Zukunft einfacher
werden ihren Vornamen und den
geschlechtseintrag im
Personenstandsregister zu ändern Trans
sind laut Gesetzentwurf Personen die
sich nicht oder nicht nur mit dem
Geschlecht identifizieren dass Ihnen bei
der Geburt zugewiesen wurde
intergeschlechtlich bedeutet angeborene
körperliche Merkmale zu haben die sich
nach medizinischen Normen nicht
eindeutig als nur männlich oder nur
weiblich einordnen lassen als nicht
binär werden Menschen definiert die sich
weder als Mann noch als Frau
identifizieren das Gesetz soll folgende
Punkte beinhalten die Änderung von
Geschlecht und Vornamen durch eine
einfache Erklärung beim Standesamt
Jugendliche ab 14 Jahren brauchen die
Zustimmung der Eltern im Streitfall
würde das Familiengericht entscheiden
unter 14 Jahren können die Eltern oder
die Sorgeberechtigten die Erklärung
abgeben die Änderung tritt erst nach
einer 3 monatigen Bedenkfrist in Kraft
theoretisch können Betroffene den
Eintrag ändern so oft Sie wollen aber es
gibt eine einjährige speerfrist eine
Regelung zu geschlechtsangleichenden
Maßnahmen soll mit dem
selbstbestimmungsgesetz nicht getroffen
werden ein inkrafttretendes Gesetzes
sieht der Entwurf zum ersten November
2024 vor
und ich freue mich dass ich darüber
jetzt sprechen kann mit Julia Monrose
ist Aktivistin und Referentin für
geschlechtliche Vielfalt und mir jetzt
aus Bremen zugeschaltet hallo Frau
Monroe
hallo schönen guten Tag danke dass Sie
sich die Zeit nehmen das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz wurde heute von
der Bundesregierung beschlossen als ein
wichtiger Schritt ist das für sie ein
Grund zum Feiern
also es ist in dem Sinne ein Grund zum
feiern weil diese
demütigungsprozedur die bisher
stattgefunden hat in dem ja über 40
Jahre alten Transsexuellengesetz wo
Trans Personen vor vor ein Gericht
treten müssen um dort einen Antrag zu
stellen und werden dort durch zwei
psychologische Sachverständigen
Gutachten
ja mit sehr übergriffigen Fragen
konfrontiert und dass dieses Prozedere
abgeschafft wird oder das ist
vereinfacht wird das ist natürlich für
uns zum feiern aber nicht nur es gibt
natürlich auch von unserer Seite noch
sehr viel Kritik an dem Gesetz weil man
uns diese es heißt ja
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das heißt wir
bestimmen ab sofort oder in der Zukunft
dann selber über unseren
geschlechtseintrag
aber man wird immer noch mit Misstrauen
irgendwie konfrontiert und das ist
natürlich ein Punkt an dem wir immer
noch sehr stark kritisieren
lassen Sie uns gleich gerne dann noch
einmal ein bisschen ausführliche drüber
sprechen wie dieses Gesetz aus ihrer
Perspektive denn weiter ausgestaltet
sein müsste
an dem was sie gerade geäußert haben
also diese dieses Prozedere was bisher
die bisherige Rechtslage hergibt das
findet auch der quebeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Sven Lehmann von den
Grünen und tragbar und er hat dazu im
Bundestag folgendes gesagt
[Applaus]
verständigen Gutachten vorliegen in den
Fragebogen tauchen dann unter anderem
solche Fragen auf ich zitiere wie oft
masturbieren sie durchschnittlich
innerhalb eines Monats und falls Sie das
Erscheinungsbild eines Mannes haben
tragen sie dann weibliche Unterwäsche um
sich zu stimulieren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das ist einfach nur
würdelos
Sven nennt es würde los wie würden sie
das beschreiben
das ist absolut demütigend also das ist
das ist übergriffig da erheben sich
Menschen darüber mich als transperson zu
beurteilen zu bewerten und zu sagen hier
haben wir bevor du dein
geschlechtsantrag ändern möchtest musst
du erstmal beweisen dass du jetzt nicht
irgendwie krank bist dass du nicht
irgendwie einem Fetisch oder irgendein
einer perversen Neigung nachgehst oder
so und da
kämpfen wir schon lange dafür dass diese
Prozedur endlich abgeschafft wird und
das wird von vielen Beteiligten von
vielen Betroffenen als demütigen
empfunden als Menschen verachten einfach
weil es geht gar nicht um meine
Sexualität das wird ja immer so in die
sexuelle Schiene gesteckt in so oder so
in die psychisch krankgeschrieben und
ähm das hier geht aber in Wirklichkeit
einfach nur um unsere eigene Identität
um die geschlechtliche Zuordnung und
nicht um irgendwie in sexuelles
Verhalten oder um unsere Sexualität oder
ähnliches
Frau Mann sie sind ja nicht nur
Aktivisten und Referentin sondern sie
beraten ja auch Jugendliche junge
Menschen oder auch Erwachsene die in
diesen Prozess sind nehmen Sie uns gerne
einmal mit sie haben es jetzt schon ein
bisschen angeschnitten Sven Lehmann hat
es in dem unter mir gerade gehört haben
ja auch gesagt aber wenn eine Person
wirklich für sich diesen Entschluss fast
der darauffolgende Prozess wie er bisher
abläuft wie muss man sich den konkret
vorstellen
also bisher ist das so dass man beim
zuständigen Amtsgericht das ist je nach
je nach Wohnort gibt es da eine
bestimmte Zuständigkeit dort muss man
erstmal einen Antrag stellen bei dem
Gericht dann entscheidet das Gericht
darüber okay du kannst diesen Antrag
stellen und du kannst dieses Verfahren
jetzt einleiten musst aber bevor wir
eine Entscheidung bevor wir ein
Gerichtsurteil bevor wir einen Beschluss
fassen musste erstmal zu einer
psychologischen Begutachtung da müssen
zwei unabhängige Sachverständige ein
Gutachten erstellen wo dann verschiedene
Fragen geklärt werden ob diese Person
wirklich dran ist ob dieses Gefühl seit
mindestens drei Jahren besteht und ob
dieses ähm mit das ist dass sich dieses
Gefühl mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht mehr ändern wird diese das sind so
die Zeit 13 zentralen die dort abgeklärt
werden müssen und in diesem
Verfahren in diesem Gutachten wird
werden dann häufig diese Fragen gestellt
also ich habe auch beispielsweise erlebt
da sollten Jugendliche sich dann
hinsetzen und mit Bauplätzen ihre
Familie nachbauen und so das geht immer
so in diese psychisch Kranke Schiene ob
man überhaupt fähig ist sich über sich
selbst zu entscheiden und ähm ja ob man
ob es überhaupt gerechtfertigt ist dass
jemand diesen Eintrag überhaupt haben
darf
wenn man sich mal versucht da rein zu
fühlen dann ist ja sozusagen die der
Impuls aus dem heraus Menschen sozusagen
diesen Wunsch äußern und sich dann auf
diesen Weg machen ja vielleicht auch gar
keine
Position der Stärke sondern diese
Menschen sind ja wahrscheinlich dann eh
auch schon in diesem Moment
sehr verunsichert und vielleicht auch in
Sorge vor dem was da auf sie zukommt was
macht dann wenn sie sagen wenn sie auch
mit diesen Menschen arbeiten
dieser Prozess wir jetzt gerade ist auch
mit denen wie belastend ist der wie muss
man sich das vorstellen
also man muss sich das erstmal
vorstellen dass man selber erstmal einen
langen Zeitraum hat bevor man sich
darüber im Klaren wird wenn man ist also
wir sprechen vom inneren Coming Out das
ist der Zeitpunkt wo ich mir darüber
bewusst werde wäre ich bin und dann
kommt irgendwann das Äußere Coming Out
dieser Prozess dauert im Schnitt so ich
sag mal vier bis sieben Jahre ungefähr
das sind so ca ca Angaben da gibt es
eine Studie zu das ist bei transmännern
unterschiedlich als bei Transfrauen
und dieser Prozess wenn das vier bis
sieben Jahre dauert bevor ich mich
selbst reflektiere und dann endlich den
Mut finde dass jemand anderes eine
andere Person
mitzuteilen und dann gesagt zu bekommen
hier im Moment das ist jetzt vielleicht
irgendwo eine Phase oder es muss jetzt
erstmal irgendwie von außen bewertet
werden also das das relativiert
eigentlich das Leid was diese Menschen
in dieser Phase durchgemacht haben wo
sie versucht haben sich selbst zu finden
wo viele ich sag mal depressive Phasen
bisschen zu Suizidalität vielleicht eine
eine Rolle gespielt haben
und dann kriegt man von außen irgendwie
gesagt oder man bekommt Ablehnung
vielleicht aus der eigenen Familie man
bekommt Schwierigkeiten in der Schule wo
jetzt die
der falsche Name noch auf dem
Abschlusszeugnis steht damit dem man
sich dann vielleicht bewerben möchte für
der für eine Ausbildung für eine
Arbeitsstelle oder ähnliches und also da
findet so viel im Alltag so viel
verletzende finden so viele Verletzungen
statt und da muss man sich in einem in
so einem gutachtenprozess da solchen
Fragen noch hingeben das ist erstmal
sehr teuer das Verfahren man rechnet so
im Schnitt 1500 bis 2000 € kosten diese
Gutachten und das Gerichtsverfahren
und wenn man das
wenn man dieses Verfahren dann
angestoßen hat und dann kriegt man
solche Fragen gestellt und dann bekommt
man auch Angst dass man sagt ich möchte
dieses Verfahren abschließen aber diese
Fragen die haben doch gar nichts mit
meiner Identität zu tun das geht ja hier
um sexuelle Fragen das hat er mit mir
als Person als Mensch mit meiner
Identität nichts zu tun und das wollen
wir dann hat man Angst zu sagen okay
wenn ich diese Frage nicht beantwortet
was passiert dann darf ich dann diesen
neuen geschlechtsantrag haben kriege ich
dann meinen neuen Vornamen und so also
man gibt sich dem hin und lässt das über
sich ergehen und macht das bringt das
möglichst schnell hinter sich damit man
endlich zu seinem Ziel kommt aber
eigentlich passiert das oftmals sehr
widerwillig
wir bekommen dazu natürlich die ganze
Zeit auch von euch Fragen und Gedanken
zu dem Thema danke dazu es schreibt zum
Beispiel adeki bei Youtube ich finde es
toll dass transmenschen es endlich etwas
leichter haben im Leben das wird ihnen
im Leben wirklich helfen dazu passt
vielleicht folgende Frage also sie haben
natürlich jetzt diesen sehr schwierigen
Weg den es bisher gibt es beschrieben
was ändert sich denn konkret durch das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz an der
Lebensrealität von Trans Inter und
intergeschlechtlichen Menschen und nicht
binären Menschen
ja also
vereinfacht wird hier lediglich das
Prozedere wir müssen nicht mehr vor ein
Gericht treten wir müssen nicht mehr
diese psychologische begutachten also
diese dritte Perspektive von ähm
psychologischen Sachverständigen oder
ein ärztliches Attest oder ähnliches
über uns gehen lassen sondern wir
alleine entscheiden darüber wer wir sind
wir gehen zum Standesamt können dort
eine Erklärung unterschreiben und und
gehören dann die dem ähm dem Geschlecht
an dass wir für uns als richtig
empfinden und was ich leider oftmals in
den Medien
beobachte ist die Diskussion das jetzt
jeder Mensch zum Standesamt gehen kann
den geschlechtseintrag ändert um dann
Zugang zu irgendwelchen Räumen zu
bekommen und so weiter also es hat
bisher noch nie irgendwie
die dazu geführt dass Menschen vor einem
feiner Toilette beispielsweise irgendwie
Nachweis werden geschlechtseintrag
bringen mussten das wird sich auch durch
dieses Gesetz nicht ändern
da wird oftmals von irgendwelchen
missbrauchsfantasien gesprochen und so
weiter das entspricht einfach nicht der
Lebensrealität
geändert wird hier lediglich das
vereinfacht wird lediglich das Prozedere
es ist nicht mehr beim Gericht sondern
beim Standesamt und es wird nur Vorname
und geschlechtseintrag verändert und
nicht irgendwie automatisch der Zugang
zu irgendwelchen Räumen gewährt das ist
ein guter Punkt den ich gleich auch noch
mal gerne mitnehme und mit meinem
Kollegen sammel Kirsch aus unserer
rechtsredaktion besprechen möchte bevor
wir das aber tun würde ich ihn gerne
noch einmal die Frage stellen sie haben
es am Anfang schon ein bisschen
angerissen was dass sie nicht so ganz
zufrieden sind mit dem Gesetzentwurf ja
jetzt auf den Weg gebracht worden ist
was fehlt ihm denn konkret was müsste
aus ihrer sich besser werden
also in dem Gesetzesentwurf ist bis
jetzt noch von dem offenbarungsverbot
die Rede das ist für uns also man
spricht da so ein bisschen von dem
zahnlosen Tiger weil die Menschen die
einen schon lange kennen oder wo der
alte Name wir sprechen die von dem
sogenannten deathame oder die alte
Anrede
wir reden vom sogenannten mistgendern
dass Menschen die einen von früher
kennen und wo das bekannt ist die die
Geschlechtsidentität oder die Geschlecht
Zugehörigkeit die einem bei Geburt
zugewiesen wurde den Menschen in das
bekannt ist die haben weiterhin das
Recht einen auch so zu benennen ohne
dass sie da irgendwelche Sanktionen
befürchten müssen und das Problem ist
aber oftmals das gerade Kinder und
Jugendliche die jetzt in ihrem
Elternhaus keine Unterstützung finden
massiv darunter leiden dass ihre Eltern
oder das soziale Umfeld keine
Unterstützung anbieten und bewusst aktiv
den falschen Namen die falsche Anrede
verwenden und das führt zu enormen
Ängsten zu sozialen Rückzug zu das so
Depressionen zu suizidalen Verhalten
Selbstverletzung und ähnliches das ist
das ist erwiesen da gibt es Studien
darüber dass ein ganz hohe Zahlen und
dass das offenbarungsverbot hier nicht
weitergreift das ist quasi den Status
Quo den wir damals schon im
Transsexuellen gesetzt hatten weiterhin
verfestigt das finden wir sehr schwierig
und da müsste meiner Meinung nach noch
mal ganz stark nachgefasst werden und
das verbessert werden
über das offenbarungsverbot sprechen wir
jetzt gleich auch noch mal Frau Monroe
vielen Dank für den Moment wir wollen
uns gleich dann auch noch mal zusammen
auf die Kritik zusammen auf die Kritik
schauen die nicht nur von ihnen kommt
sondern auch aus der anderen Richtung
beispielsweise aus der Opposition dazu
gleich sprechen wir uns jetzt würde ich
aber gerne erstmal vorher mit meinem
Kollegen sammel Kirsch sprechen aus
unserer ZDF rechtsredaktion hallo Samuel
schön dass du bei mir bist hallo
lass uns gerne einfach am Anfang die
Frage aufnehmen die kam hier bei YouTube
von Martin Schmidt wenn ich mein
Geschlecht nach einer Woche dann wieder
ändern möchte kann ich das tun das geht
nicht also da hat tatsächlich der
Gesetzgeber bzw man muss ja sagen es ist
bislang ein Entwurf der noch durch den
Bundestag muss eine Frist vorgesehen die
beträgt ein Jahr gilt allerdings nicht
für Minderjährige aber ab 18 jedenfalls
ist eine rückänderung oder eine weitere
Änderung des geschlechtsantrags und des
Vornamens erst nach einer Frist von
einem Jahr möglich okay also dieses nach
einem Jahr zurück und willkürlich hin
und her das ist nicht möglich auf dieser
Grundlage nach einem Jahr schon aber
eben nicht innerhalb dieses ein
Jahresfrist genau
es gibt jetzt ja auch von Kritikern die
Behauptung Eltern könnten in Teilen auch
also bei minderjährigen Kindern
logischerweise ohne die Einwilligung des
Kindes den geschlechtseintrag ändern
lassen was ist da dran ja insbesondere
bei den Kindern unter 14 Jahren könnte
man den Eindruck gewinnen wenn man den
Gesetzentwurf so liest weil dort ist es
so dass der Antrag tatsächlich nicht
gestellt wird von den Kindern selbst
beim Standesamt sondern das müssen die
Eltern machen das kommt also erstmal
tatsächlich auf den Willen der Eltern
oder der Sorgeberechtigten an aber die
dürfen sich nicht einfach so willkürlich
über den Willen ihres Kindes
hinwegsetzen sondern es ist ganz klar
bei einer so weitreichenden Entscheidung
die die Identität des Kindes so
tiefgreifend betrifft da muss auch das
Kind der Wille des Kindes
Berücksichtigung finden hier älter es
wird desto eher je geistig reifer es ist
und hier er ist auch die Tragweite
dieser Entscheidung abschätzen kann dass
du irgendwas das eingebunden werden und
wenn das nicht geschieht wenn also die
Eltern noch gar nicht mit dem Kind
sprechen und sich über dessen Willen
hinwegsetzen dann kann das ein Indiz
dafür sein dass das Kindeswohl gefährdet
ist und gegen eine Kindeswohlgefährdung
da gibt es rechtliche Schutzmechanismen
da könnte dann das Familiengericht auf
dem Plan gerufen werden sich auch selbst
einschalten und im Zweifel wenn das
Kindeswohl tatsächlich gefährdet ist und
der Wille des Kindes nicht zum Tragen
kommt den Willen der Eltern ersetzen und
ihn im schlimmsten Falle sogar das
Sorgerecht entziehen verstehe sammel
lass uns gerne noch einmal auf die zwei
Punkte schauen die Frau Monroe auch
angesprochen hatte und zwar zum einen
diese sogenannten Schutzräume und zum
anderen das offenbarungsverbot jetzt ist
ja eine Kritik auch an diesem
selbstbestimmungsgesetz dass dieses
Gesetz eben zum Beispiel Männern
ermöglichen könnte in Schutzräume für
Frauen einzudringen indem sie dann eben
sagen ich bin jetzt eine Frau ich lasse
das entsprechend ändern und marschiere
dann da rein im Gesetzentwurf findet
sich jetzt aber sehr prominent auch der
Hinweis dass weiterhin das Hausrecht
geht beispielsweise bei einer bei einer
frauenauna ist das denn überhaupt nötig
rechtlich nötig in dem Sinne ist das
eigentlich nicht denn es ist eine
Klarstellung die sagt eigentlich gilt
die Rechtslage die auch vorher schon
galt also das selbstbestimmungsgesetz
lässt das Hausrecht eben unberührt ich
denke aber das kann sich so
interpretieren lassen dass insbesondere
die Justizminister hier zeigen wollte
den Kritikern wir sehen diesen Punkt und
wir haben ihn beachtet und wir stellen
klar das Hausrecht bleibt hier unberührt
das Hausrecht das bedeutet etwa ein
privater Betreiber einer Sauna der kann
durchaus
Menschen abweisen den Zutritt verwehren
von seinem Hausrecht Gebrauch machen die
beispielsweise männliche
Geschlechtsmerkmale tragen aber nicht
einfach so weil er das so gerne möchte
willkürlich sondern es braucht einen
sachlichen Grund und der kann aber eben
darin liegen dass Frauen die diese Sauna
regelmäßig besuchen in ihrer Intimität
in ihrem Bedürfnis nach Intimsphäre
geschützt werden sollen und diesen Grund
kann eben weiterhin Rechnungen getragen
werden durchausschluss von Personen die
dem geschlechtsantrag haben ändern
lassen okay verstehe bisschen sperrig
klingt ja dieser Begriff des
offenbarungsverbots das sagt im Grunde
aus dass auf Grundlage des Gesetzes ein
Bußgeld verhängt werden kann so steht es
drin wenn jemand die Änderung des
geschlechtseintrags von
transgeschlechtlichen nicht binären oder
intergeschlechtlichen Personen gegen
deren Willen offenbart und dadurch die
betroffene Person absichtlich schädigt
ist das eine wirksame rechtliche
Grundlage um dem vorzubeugen ja Frau
Monroe hat ja schon einen Punkt
angesprochen es gibt gewisse Ausnahmen
eine besteht insbesondere darin dass
eine Offenbarung der vorherigen
etikettiert oder das vorherigen
geschlechtsantrags voraussetzt und das
steht auch so ein Gesetzentwurf dass das
bisher noch nicht bekannt ist also
nehmen wir den Fall eines Prominenten
bei dem vorher allseits öffentlich
bekannt ist welche geschlechtsantrag er
hatte er lässt ihn jetzt ändern dann ist
er durch diesen dieses
offenbarungsverbot sich geschützt weil
eben gar nichts mehr da ist was es zu
offenbaren gilt gleiches Bild
beispielsweise in der Situation dass
zwei Nachbarn die beide Kenntnis haben
über den geschlechtsantrag sich über den
Vorgang unterhalten auch hier wäre kein
Bußgeld möglich man muss aber auch sehen
das ist ein Interessenausgleich
letztlich greift sondern
offenbarungsverbot auch ein Stück weit
ein in die Möglichkeit sich frei zu
äußern und auch das muss der Gesetzgeber
berücksichtigen und ich denke diese
Einschränkungen sind ein Stück weit der
Versuch da einen ausgewogene Balance zu
finden was noch eine wichtige Hürde ist
ist dieses Erfordernis dass es eine
Schädigungsabsicht braucht also dass
jemand nur einen Bußgeld bekommen kann
nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit geht wenn
die Offenbarung des vorherigen
geschlechtsantrags oder des vorherigen
Vornamens wenn die geschieht um
denjenigen zu schädigen das kann im
Einzelfall ganz schön schwierig sein das
nachzuweisen ist also auch eine
wichtige Hürde die man erstmal nehmen
jedenfalls erfasst denke ich werden
Fälle von wirklich Mobbing wo also einem
Person bloßgestellt werden soll und
diffamiert werden soll indem man ihre
vorherige Identität
Geschlechtsidentität offenbart und daher
wahrscheinlich von Frau Monroe auch noch
mal der der Hinweis oder der Appell an
der Stelle danach zu bessern bei dem
Gesetz lass uns gerne abschließend noch
einmal kurz auf eine auf eine Frage
eingehen die kommt von Peter Gebhard hat
er uns per Mail geschickt wie wirkt sich
einen Namensänderung auf bestehende
privatrechtliche Verträge aus Schutz des
anderen Vertragspartners schreibt er
ja
das gibt teilweise ist auch in diesem
offenbarungsverbot berücksichtigt
tatsächlich auch ein rechtliches
Interesse wenn man einen Vertragspartner
hat und der lässt das Geschlecht
umtragen vom Standesamt dann kann es
durchaus ein rechtliches Interesse geben
seines Vertragspartners darüber Kenntnis
zu erlangen wenn er beispielsweise
Schulden hat und er die Vollstreckung
einleiten will das heißt er will diese
Schulden eintreiben dann braucht er den
aktuellen Namen und dann kann er da
tatsächlich eine Auskunft verlangen okay
sammelkirsch aus unserer ZDF
rechtsredaktion danke dass du ins Studio
gekommen bist und danke für deine
Antworten
und ich würde jetzt gerne noch einmal
sprechen mit Frau
Monroe sie ist wie gesagt uns
zugeschaltet die ganze Zeit aus Bremen
sie ist Aktivistin und Referentin für
geschlechtliche Vielfalt Frau manno sie
selbst haben Kritik an diesem
Gesetzentwurf von der von Kabinett
beschlossen wurde Gesetz kommt aber auch
von anderen unter anderem aus der Union
da heißt es das befürchtet wird
Jugendliche würden während der Pubertät
voreilige Entscheidung über eigene
Geschlechtsangleichung treffen jetzt
muss man das an der Stelle auch noch mal
darauf hinweisen haben Sie auch schon
getan in dem Gesetzentwurf geht es
explizit nicht um medizinische Maßnahmen
was sagen sie trotzdem zu dieser Kritik
also ich finde dass die Union da
versucht
sich wie soll ich sagen
einem Thema zu nähern um irgendwie auf
Stimmenfang zu gehen und ähnliches also
die wissen eigentlich dass das gar keine
das ist da gar kein Zusammenhang gibt es
geht nur um den geschlechtseintrag es
geht nicht um den Zugang zu
irgendwelchen medizinischen Maßnahmen da
gibt es ganz andere
Prozesse die dann durch Krankenkasse und
medizinischer Dienst angestoßen werden
die auch über Monate über Jahre dauern
bis man überhaupt dazu kommt dass
überhaupt irgendwelche Maßnahmen oder
sei es äh Hormontherapie oder ähnliches
eingeleitet wird also der wird meiner
Meinung nach bewusst mit ja mit falschen
Informationen auch gearbeitet um das
Ganze in eine Richtung zu lenken die
vielleicht der eigenen Wählerschaft
irgendwie
verdienen soll
wir wissen dass gerade Trans Jugendliche
im Durchschnitt ich glaube es sind
4,5 bis 6,8 Jahre brauchen um sich über
ihre eigene Geschlechtsidentität bewusst
zu werden wir wissen auch dass ungefähr
im Alter von achteinhalb Jahren die
meisten transgeschlechtlichen Menschen
wissen was für eine Geschlechtsidentität
sie haben und wenn man sich diesen
Zeitraum von von vier bis sieben Jahren
ungefähr anschaut da da ist ein ganz
langer reflexionszeitraum vorher
gegangen und dann noch mal diesen diesen
über heilungsschutz irgendwie dort im
Gesetz mit anzuführen dass er das ist
irgendwie ein Schlag ins Gesicht für die
Person und dass man Ihnen immer noch
nicht zutraut dass Sie wissen wer sie
sind
das wäre tatsächlich meine nächste Frage
gewesen weil sie haben ja unter anderem
dieses Projekt Transits ins Leben
gerufen wo sie eben Kinder und
Jugendliche und deren Angehörigen die
eben im Prozess oder davor sind
begleiten das heißt sie kennen da ganz
viele Schicksale was dieses Thema angeht
ist das denn wenn wir jetzt mal diese
medizinischen Maßnahmen Stichwort
Geschlechtsangleichung aus dem vorlassen
ist das denn überhaupt eine realistische
Gefahr dass wenn der Weg jetzt sozusagen
vereinfacht wird dass davor einige
Entscheidung getroffen werden
also ich habe in meiner eigenen Gruppe
bisher noch nie eine Person erlebt die
tatsächlich gesagt hat hier das ist
jetzt der der falsche Weg für mich ich
möchte das alles wieder rückgängig
machen und so weiter oder ähnliches ich
habe aber mal eine Person erlebt die bei
uns in die Gruppe gekommen ist die
gesagt sich erst als lesbisch geoutet
hatten dann gesagt hat nee ich bin Trans
und dann war sie über den Zeitraum von
einem halben Jahr bis
dreiviertel Jahr glaube ich bei uns in
der Gruppe und hat mir dann irgendwann
die Mitteilung gemacht dass dass sie
vielleicht doch nicht dran ist
bevor es dann überhaupt zu dem Zeitpunkt
kommt hier ich möchte jetzt irgendwie
Hormone nehmen oder ähnliches also da
finden das ist auch Teil dieses
reflexionprozesses die Leute die dann
meistens in die Beratungsstelle kommen
die Fragen die wissen eigentlich schon
sehr genau wer sie sind die haben sich
informiert die haben ihren Prozess mit
sich selbst abgeklärt oftmals schon mit
den Eltern wenn die das alles mittragen
da schon abgeklärt und kommen dann
meistens schon mit der Frage ja wie kann
ich jetzt den Weg beschreiten wo kann
ich eine passende Psychotherapie
bekommen wie kann ich insbesondere mit
dem Thema an der Schule an meine Schule
herantreten weil das der Name auf dem
Zeugnis oder im Klassenbuch immer ein
ganz großes Thema ist und so
also diese Gefahr die da ja so groß
gemacht wird die sehe ich die sehe ich
da nicht also aus der Beratungs aus dem
Beratungsalltag da ist das bisher kein
großes Thema wir wissen auch dass wenn
es Leute gibt die sich
wirklich oder die wirklich irgendwann zu
der Erkenntnis kommen okay das war
vielleicht doch nicht der richtige Weg
also ich habe mal mit einem der
Chirurgen gesprochen die das seit 30
Jahren praktizieren und dann gesagt
haben hier ich habe in 30 Jahren 3000
Operationen durchgeführt und davon kam
insgesamt drei Menschen die gesagt haben
hier das waren Fehler das da kann man
sich schon ausrechnen wie groß dieser
Prozentsatz ist und das sind wirklich
ganz ganz wenige und in meiner
Beratungsstelle ist das so in der Form
bisher noch nicht vorgekommen
dazu passt vielleicht die Frage von Sven
oder die er uns bei Youtube gestellt hat
wird das Kind denn vor der möglichen
geschlechtsänderung gemeint die
Geschlechtsangleichung angehört und eine
genannte Kindeswohlgefährdung oder
Manipulation des Kindes zu verhindern
angehört von wem ist jetzt die Frage
also die das Kind kommt meistens mit mit
den Eltern zusammen bei mir in die
Beratungsstelle und dann wird natürlich
darüber gesprochen welche Möglichkeiten
gibt es ich persönlich sag den immer
lasst euch Zeit
nehmt euch die Zeit mit gerade also
viele kommen in die Beratungsstelle
wollen alles auch sehr schnell haben
aber ich versuchte dann immer so zu
sensibilisieren dass sie jetzt um Jahre
voraus sind gegenüber ihren Eltern die
Eltern weil Wissen quasi erst ab
tagsüber ab Tag X Bescheid und die
Jugendlichen haben jetzt aber schon
jahrelang ihren inneren Prozess gehabt
und darüber nachgedacht und reflektiert
und jetzt werden die Eltern damit
konfrontiert und müssen jetzt erstmal
langsam mitgenommen und da versuche ich
immer zu raten geht das Ganze langsam an
geht das ganze bedacht anredet mit euren
Eltern darüber schaut die Reaktionen in
eurem Umfeld im Freundeskreis an und so
und natürlich wird auch darüber
gesprochen welche
welche Folgen dann eine Hormontherapie
haben können
natürlich bevor es dann auch zur
Operationen kommt wird finden natürlich
Aufklärungsgespräche in den Kliniken
statt etc also das ist das klingt immer
so als wenn man heute den
geschlechtsantrag ändert und morgen dann
auf dem OP-Tisch liegt das ist faktisch
nicht so da finden lange abklärungs- und
Aufklärungsgespräche statt und
ja da also da sehe ich eigentlich keine
großartigen Gefahren die das ganze
ja in Gefahr oder wo wo man da ein
Risiko sehen kann könnte
über die Kritik von politischer Seite
haben wir schon kurz gesprochen ich
würde gerne noch einmal mit ihnen auf
eine ja sehr kritische Stimme zu diesem
Thema schauen die vor allem seit gestern
viel diskutiert und zitiert wird und
zwar von alles schwarzer also im
Interview mit dem Spiegel gestern
folgendes gesagt
es gibt einen modischen Trend für junge
Leute Trans zu sein das ist schick die
Zahl der Menschen die sich für
transhalten ist innerhalb weniger Jahre
in der ganzen westlichen Welt extrem
gestiegen vor allem unter Jugendlichen
etwa 80% von denen sind Mädchen in
manchen Klassen sitzen heutzutage gleich
drei oder vier die sagen sie sein Trans
das ist ja tatsächlich was was man auch
aus vielen anderen Ecken hört nicht aus
hacken sondern aus Ecken Transsexualität
als Trend was sagen sie dazu
ja das ist leider ein Phänomen was uns
immer wieder begegnet oder was uns immer
wieder vorgeworfen wird dass das
irgendwie jetzt eine Modeerscheinung ist
ich kann dazu nur sagen dass es nicht
cool ist irgendwie Trans zu sein das ist
kein Spaß macht sich irgendwie in allen
Lebenslagen diskriminieren zu lassen
da findet
sehr lange innerer leidensprozess statt
da ist ein sehr hoher psychischer
Leidensdruck auch der gesellschaftlich
in erster Linie gesellschaftlich
verursacht wird durch bestimmte
Rollenbilder die in unsere Gesellschaft
herrschen dass ein Mann so und so zu
sein hat und eine Frau hat so und so zu
sein und so weiter
wir haben sehr stark mit behördlicher
diskrimin also struktureller
Diskriminierung an Behörden etc zu
kämpfen wir werden im Transport werden
wird im Sport werden wir kritisiert als
Trans Person die dort auch keinen Platz
finden man hat oftmals Schwierigkeiten
am Arbeitsplatz wobei sich das auch
mittlerweile langsam gebessert hat man
wird gesellschaftlich angefangen man
wird angegriffen verprügelt wir hatten
dieses Jahr ein Todesfall in Münster wo
ein Transmann
verprügelt wurde und an den Folgen
gestorben ist also es macht garantiert
keinen Spaß dran zu sein es macht
garantiert keine keine Laune irgendwie
das ist nicht cool das ist nicht trendy
ich kann es nicht verstehen dass Leute
die lange Zeit feministische Kämpfe oder
feministische Errungenschaften erkämpft
haben sich plötzlich so positionieren
und also dieses Leid was diese Menschen
betrifft dass das so relativiert wird
also es ist nicht cool sozusagen da
stecken ganz lange Leidenswege dahinter
und wir wissen ganz genau wie viel
ja wie viel Kriminalität auch nach wie
vor gegen Trans Personen ausgeübt wird
und wir haben im Schnitt es gibt so eine
Organisation die weltweit die die Morde
an Trans Person erfasst wobei das auch
ganz
nur das hält ist wir haben im Schnitt
ungefähr eine Trans Person die weltweit
pro Tag ermordet wird nur weil sie weil
sie halt Trans ist und das dann so zu
relativieren und zu sagen hier das ist
irgendwie cool das ist trendy das hat
man bei
beim Thema ADHS damals gemacht das ist
dann auch eine Mode eine Modediagnose
gewesen angeblich
wir wissen dass 15 Prozent sich
mittlerweile gerade unter Jugendlichen
sich als bisexuell identifizieren und
das ist auch in den letzten Jahren
gestiegen da sagt niemand dass es
irgendwie ein Trend ist bisexuell zu
sein aber so bei Trans Personen bei
Trans Jugendlichen wird es immer direkt
als Trend dargestellt also wissen dass
in allen Altersstufen also es gibt
Untersuchungen die
verschiedene Generationen untersucht
haben und da gibt es ein allen Bereichen
egal ob es um Homosexualität oder
Bisexualität oder transl
Geschlechtlichkeit oder nicht binarität
geht in allen Bereichen sind diese
Zahlen nach und nach angestiegen das hat
damit zu tun dass ich die gesetzliche
Situation insgesamt verbessert hat ich
sag mal es gibt jetzt die Ehe für alle
beispielsweise
und dadurch gibt es insgesamt eine
höhere Akzeptanz innerhalb der
Gesellschaft und dadurch finden
natürlich auch Jugendliche eher den Mut
sich zu offenbaren sich zu
sich zu stehen und zu zeigen zu sagen
wer Sie sind und das war in der
Vergangenheit eben nicht der Fall
homosexuelle Männer wurden verfolgt etc
also da das als trendy ab zu tun das
finde ich
sehr schwierig
sie führen ja diese Debatte die wie sie
sagen in Teilen auch sehr schwierig ist
schon lange und beteiligen sich auch
schon lange daran die wird ja auch das
Gesetz ist natürlich noch nicht in Kraft
diese Debatte wird auch noch weitergehen
was wünschen sie sich denn abschließend
wie diese Debatte denn besser oder
anders laufen könnte
also ich würde mir wünschen dass
Menschen die sich bevor sie sich dazu
äußern sich erstmal mit Trans Personen
unterhalten dass man sich vielleicht
irgendwie im Dialog zusammenfindet und
dass man sich informiert über die
wirkliche Lebensrealität dieser
Minderheit
ich wünsche mir dass man da empathische
an die Sache rangeht und nicht ständig
mit irgendwelchen Vorurteilen mit
Unwissen mit Nichtwissen mit falschen
Informationen irgendwie dass man sich an
den richtigen Quellen informiert und
dass man ja mit uns als Trans Person als
transorganisationen irgendwie ins
Gespräch kommt und einfach sich mal mit
der Lebensrealität dieser Menschen
auseinandersetzt
sagt Julian anrufen vielen Dank dass Sie
sich heute Abend die Zeit und die Zeit
genommen haben mit mir zu sprechen und
die ganzen vielen Fragen zu beantworten
und dazu würde ich gerne auch noch mal
einen Kommentar Vorlesen der bei Youtube
gekommen ist jede jeder sollte so leben
wie es ihnen sie glücklich macht solange
ist niemandem schadet wir haben heute
gesprochen über das sogenannte
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das ist vom
Bundeskabinett von der Bundesregierung
jetzt beschlossen worden im nächsten
Schritt muss es in den Bundesrat und
dann in den Bundestag die müssen sich
damit befassen und dieses
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das soll dann
nach jetziger Planung am 1 November 2024
in Kraft steht in Kraft treten danke
dass ihr dabei wart danke für eure
Fragen für eure Anregungen und bis zum
nächsten Mal